[Music]
jack
hey neil
what's the brightest star in the
nighttime sky
um
are we talking my career here neil
i've been waiting for us to get around
to this
how bright is your star jack
jack neil
so it turns out
tidal forces
are very sensitive
to distance
very sensitive in other words but not
emotionally sensitive but if you change
the distance by a little bit
it'll have a much bigger effect than
you'd otherwise think on the strength of
the tides
okay now i can't get over thinking about
emotionally sensitive tidal forces
where all of our oceans are just like
where you go
what did i do
what did i do
you said that it's you it's not me but
did i deserve this why didn't right
you just gonna throw away everything we
had
as you slowly drift away
you're so distant
i don't understand
why we don't communicate anymore
you're so distant all you have to do is
talk why are you so distant
there's a space between us
[Laughter]
i don't know how to fill this chasm
between us
i can't do all the work here
okay i'm earth and i can't do all the
work
chuck how many hours of therapy have you
been in with your wife
yes good to see you always thanks for
showing up for these these little
explainer videos well thanks for doing
them chuck yes i'm excited about this
one i want to talk about the moon okay
all right now there's a lot of these
where we talk about the moon but i want
to put it all in one place at one time
here and now all right that sounds good
all right all right uh it's just
every
moon joke yeah every every mooning
yes i'm right now i'm just putting
myself in the mental space
to stop thinking about butts
and cracks and all of that all of that
moon okay
chuck hey neil how's it going yeah about
this time of year your name
shows up i see it in emails and in
announcements and you're like hosting
earth day events that i'm just proud of
you for being out there on this i want
to tell you about how your brain is
wired
uh
poorly would be the answer
okay
like a like a house with with a bad
electricity
an unlicensed electrician right this
brain
yeah scotch tape all right all right we
have hardly any experience
thinking exponentially about the world
okay
hardly any okay so you can think let's
let's give some other examples you can
think back to your grandparents all
right you
surely met them or knew them probably
not your great-grandparents i knew mine
you did you so you knew them they lived
alone they lived a very long good time
my great-grandmother lived a very long
time your grandfather i think she killed
him okay
but she was still here
i don't know why that's even plausible
you know it's like yeah you can picture
that right
um
she killed him but she's otherwise doing
fine right well other than that she was
great
and what's she doing now oh six to ten
and
right exactly stuck yes you get tired of
these these explainers of course not i
and here's an example of why
if i say to you chuck
i'll meet you tomorrow morning at 10
o'clock
i'll say great what are we doing i'm so
excited to find out okay i love when you
surprised me like this well okay okay i
can do that but i'll say all right
that's fine i'll meet you at the corner
of 5th avenue and 34th street
okay
what's your next question to me and
you'll win because i don't want to stay
there all day waiting for you that's my
my favorite comedian and did i ever tell
you that jack i never told you that only
every day but i
but i will accept it whenever i hear it
neil
[Music]